تم نقل 20 مريضًا إلى
المستشفى
في حالة خطيرة وصغيرة
[موسيقى]
كان عددًا كبيرًا من الأشخاص في مكان ما
حوالي 10 10 أو نحو ذلك
يعانون من أنف وقيء
وهو ليس في الحقيقة إصابة ولكنه مجرد
عواقب للحركة المتطرفة
لذلك هذا  عندما نقول أن هناك 36
شخصًا مصابًا ، فهذا لا
يعني بالضرورة أنهم أصيبوا ، فهذا يعني فقط
الحاجة إلى رعاية طبية بحيث
يشمل الأشخاص الذين يعانون من إصابات فعلية
بالإضافة إلى الغثيان والقيء فقط في
الأساس بسبب دوار الحركة
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
أم لا ،  لن أقول أنه شائع بشكل خاص
، أعني أنه غالبًا ما يكون هناك
اضطراب في جميع أنحاء المحيط الهادئ ، ولكن من
النادر وجود هذا المستوى من
الاضطراب الشديد وهذا ما تسبب في
التحدي اليوم أنه كان
حالة شديدة للغاية من التوربيليونات الجوية
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك
[  الموسيقى]
ربما كان الموقع الأكثر اضطرابًا
كنا نسافر إليه كثيرًا
لم نكن بالضرورة قلقين من حدوث أي
شيء ولكن
حدث اضطراب  كان ce حقًا روكي حقًا ،
كنا أكثر توترًا لأننا كنا على
وشك التقيؤ ونمرض
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لذا سنعمل مع
NTSB نظرًا
لتعرضنا لإصابات كبيرة في هذا الأمر ، سيريد
mtsb المشاركة وسنقوم بذلك  نعمل
معهم وسنوفر بيانات من
بيانات الرحلة المسجلة لفهم
ما حدث بالضبط ،
ومن الواضح أننا سنجري مقابلات مع جميع أفراد الطاقم
الذين يحاولون فهم كيفية حدوث ذلك